the council is assembled because the
trailers don't stop so welcome to
council of geeks my name is Nathaniel
Wayne and I am joined today by Ryan
Daley polsku veto and we're going to
talk about the smorgasbord of trailers
that have been coming out I don't know
how much time we're going to spend on
each of them but holy God I don't know
when this was declared trailer season I
suppose if we're going reaching back a
little ways we can start with civil war
captain america civil war I'm really
excited about this movie I want to see
this movie I want to see this movie for
reasons that I was unhappy with age of
Ultron from the first beat of this
trailer I've invested in the story and I
care what about what's going on and I
care about these characters I like the
actors that are in these roles and I
think this trailer is the perfect amount
of story to get me engaged now I also
know what happens in the Civil War Tom
straight line from the comics and I
thought it was kind of dumb and I think
this is a much better and cooler way to
tell this story I agree I having read
the Civil War comic book storyline and
not really liking the way was presented
i think that the differences that the
film will make will be for the better of
the film I it really got me said I was
already excited for because I like
Captain America this movie has a lot of
other things that I'm excited about that
we saw in this little teaser trailer
just a few glimpses of Black Panthers
you know my favorite Marvel characters
that suit looks really cool it does and
it got me really really excited fat what
I was really impressed with this trailer
was actually how small the scale felt
and I and I mean that in a very good way
because I think the problem with the
comic book version of this story was
they came up with the concept of let's
divide our universe and just have them
fight each other and then tried to
justify that after they already had that
concept and they came at it from this
led to make it big angle whereas I
really feel like this movie is let's
make it personal and you and you get
from Tony that line you know when
cap says he's my friend and Tony
responds so was I right heartbreaking
whoa yeah especially and it works cuz
they're rooting it in the characters as
opposed to rooting it in the big concept
which was which was what the comic book
did and that line right I want to see
the moment where cap makes the decision
to punch Tony the first punch that's
that reference that's got to be a
powerful moment that film I want to see
that any surprises or questions about
the things that were not included in
this trailer or specifically characters
that have been confirmed to appear in
that were you disappointed you didn't
see spider-man no I think that would
have been a huge mistake to put him in
the first trailer because it would have
dominated the conversation coming out of
it yes I'm think it'll be similar to how
the vision was rolled out and where we
gotta just a glimpse of like his face
and close up in a trailer that I think
him out March when that when age of
Ultron came out in May yeah and then the
TV spots that rolled out like the week
or two like you saw him saw from behind
so it was flying I think I think you
will see him but I I think it'll
probably be the last trailer before the
movie comes out and I think they'll
probably see his web before we'll see
anything else mmm maybe me how I think
they'll probably do it DC's answer to
that which is Batman V Superman and the
new trailer that came out and I've sort
of done my own video in my own thoughts
on that so I'll for the time being i'll
hold back and let you guys have at it
this trailer i thought started bad and
got worse and they have their dialogue
and it's full of you know you know you
know veiled lines like we don't we don't
like clowns and everything but do you
think Batman and it's in the dialogue
itself is fine but the way the trailer
positions over this egg driving music
dunham mmmmmm and we're like getting all
these cutscenes of like what Batman is
doing in action and everything with this
dialogue that's supposed to be clever
and tongue and cheek and it's just not
working for me at the moment I was just
like we need to get out of this scene
and then up yah Jesse Eisenberg's Lex
Luthor I wanted to punch my computer
screen him to just to get in
so right from that first thing I was
like I don't like this and then of
course the the biggest problem which is
they showed us at three yeah that's okay
i guess we're seeing this but what did
you think I've talked enough that um so
this was the very first time that I
actually felt hopeful about this film
when I saw the trailer I was like okay I
kind of like this I like the measuring
each other up my first thought about
Jesse Eisenberg was and I said this to
you was that I they needed to do
something different with Lex and it's
okay to reinterpret these characters it
is ok to have a new young version of Lex
Luthor right and and I think that's fine
he is grading mom and annoying I mean
that's where it falls down because they
know theory I agree with everything you
just said yeah except that it doesn't
matter because I'm my teeth were
grinding when he spoke Rena's Luthor we
knew that one of them wasn't going to
die and eventually they were going to
come together and they were going to
form adjust we knew they were going to
be friends by the end of it but this
shows us that it's before the end of it
that yes they they do fight something
else together side by side and we know
what that is now we've seen that and we
know who helps them in that fight yes
and also it's a mutual enemy but and so
they both help each other fight this
thing with Wonder Woman and maybe I'll
crow man shows up eventually um but
wouldn't anybody as I said I am I still
there are lots of things I hate right I
hate the palette i hate the way in what
a woman is introduced i hate um well is
it here's the thing i actually really
like the way she's introduced i just
hate that i now know it before i go and
see the movie I think that's my ultimate
issue with this trailer is not that it
made me go well I'm not going to like
this movie it made me go I now don't
need to see this movie it's it's also
kind of a weird trailer most trailers
now run between two and two and a half
minutes which I think might be too long
yeah this one is over three minutes so
you gotta wonder
at one point it's like why didn't you
stop and then the last thing going back
to aesthetics um Ben Affleck as Batman I
think he looks really fat in the suit I
can't get over this I think I think he
looks really fat in the super haha I
have that I'm a dad like I 1 i'm the
only one who makes that complaint so
nobody else notices it but well I mean I
notice he look big it looks a little
snug instance like I saw the first
promotional like magazine cover with the
three of them standing together I think
it just it makes his facebook fat like
x-men apocalypse I know I'll start on
this one because I have a feeling that I
was more positive on this than you guys
and I think that probably has to do with
the fact that I also liked x-men days of
future past more than either of you did
um but there was actually there was a
fair amount I liked about this trailer
but the one thing I want to single out
and I maybe it's a weird thing to single
out but it made me so happy is there is
no modulation or modification of Oscar
Isaacs voice he is such a good actor
mm-hmm and I i I've never not seen him
turning a great performance and the rest
of it that was mostly just cool fine
looks looks like it works the olean that
seemed off to me I wasn't loving um
unfortunately forget the actress's name
but so I'll just go with Sansa Starks
line reading as young Jean Grey I did
not love it felt very forced and kind of
wouldn't I'm just hoping it works better
in context um I was actually surprised
they didn't do anything to Oscar Isaacs
voice because with a character like
Apocalypse I really expect it clearly
enough people have complained about
other characters voices being mentally
modulated so they might be saying like
let's just around the side of caution
Oscar Isaac can talk with let him talk
and if that's the best thing for the
movie than fine it just it shocked me
and almost made me nervous like
skeptical just like I did like this
weird gut-check rossak what why does his
voice sound normal then harden I finish
hahaha
having been so disappointed with Days of
Future past this movie needed to do a
lot more to get me enthusiastic and
interested and it didn't get to that
point like the hair in the fashion for
the 80s I'm digging well the first time
we see Charles Xavier and he's got like
the the checkered suit jacket and like a
purple t-shirt that was it yeah he looks
like flock of seagulls they showed
apocalypse for the first time I think at
comic-con they showed what he looked
like you know the reaction from the
crowd no and it was quickly followed by
people saying like you looked like
something out of Mighty Morphin Power
Ranger guy have a news it right anyway
we were like joking there like no
seriously put a side-by-side comparison
art oh god it looks like something out
of Mighty Morphin Power Rangers they
seem to have made some color Corrections
yeah it looks a lot more blue than white
purple or pink yeah but it also I it
seemed to me like they were doing their
best to hide what apocalypse looks like
which either means they're making
corrections in post to try and change
his appearance or they don't know what
to do but they're trying to keep them
out of you because they don't want
people to reject him before they see the
movie for my money it's the first of
those two because I did notice that the
shot the few shots we get him particular
look very heavily color corrected when
they were they basically a gray overlay
which turns the purple blue and which I
think could probably be justified
because it also looked like in the
background like there were clouds above
so if if he just goes around and brings
his own thunderstorm with him fine you
can justify that the lighting changing
is easily enough so this movie right is
supposed to be the payoff for these
other two so for me the stakes for this
film should be pretty dang high and I
should feel particularly compelled to go
see this movie because of the things
that should be at stake I do not feel
any of those things having watched this
trailer I don't feel like it is the
payoff for what I've watched and I don't
feel I watched it I wasn't I was so
excited for days of future past I should
be excited to go see this movie
um and I'm not I don't know necessarily
what the stakes are I don't know what
apocalypses endgame or his mission is
within this movie and coming off of the
last one where the stakes were robot
apocalypse and total extinction which we
actually saw we saw brighter future was
like it how dark it was like if
apocalypse isn't getting us to that
level what is he doing and and it feels
like that's it's almost an impossibly
high tacker for a new villain but when
his name is apocalypse Jesus something
that I forgot a little things that I am
intrigued I I want to see I want to see
please give me more characters than just
Xavier Megiddo and mystique I want to
see the young Cyclops in a young night
crawler and a young storm doing stuff I
like sea storm with a mohawk um I didn't
hate the the trailer but it also didn't
do what it needed to be to get me back
after my disappointment in the last one
but I'm also in the minority and
disappointing or in not liking the last
one the two of us were the only ones
well we're the majority in this room at
once in the larger community a lot of
people loved the last ex mentally a Star
Trek beyond of Miss recently yeah I mean
you start on this one okay don't take it
go for it so here's the thing about this
love Star Trek loved injure darkness
right um I saw the trailer for this and
I'm like I don't care and I'm like oh so
they're stranded there somewhere um okay
it's a funny I guess I really wanted to
like this trailer and I I'm gonna have
to see more if I'm gonna want to see
this movie I didn't love the trailer I
think the approach they took was an odd
one for them to take as much as I liked
into darkness and I know you did it was
a very divisive film mm-hmm and they
have presented us with the trailer that
I think only would have worked coming
off of a more universally loved film
because the trailer is just kind of a
hey here it is it's coming out and if
you if you're skeptical on it I mean you
weren't skeptical it's still
work for you but for my mind if you're
skeptical on any level of this franchise
at this point this thing doesn't try and
convince it doesn't give you a reason to
see the movie the song the song just I
didn't even feel like it was
disconnected or didn't belong it just to
me I herbicide my response was there
trying too hard to make me feel
certainly it should give me something
and then like that and combine was
saying it's like produced by JJ but from
the director of the fast enough ok I'm
not I'm not just that I haven't seen the
Fast and the Furious movies but a lot of
people have and they're certainly
popular enough but I was like so I'm not
holding that against it but it was just
like okay we're going for this full
throttle high octane like kind of type
type of movie I was like I was kind of
hoping they would go a little bit more
towards classic Star Trek and this feels
like we're gonna make it look like that
but it's not gonna feel anything like
that and and I don't know like the
little character beats I was fine with i
like the little thing with mccoy and spa
that was i usually i thought that way
when he's like at least i won't die
alone and Spock is beamed out of there
looks like he's surprised when he's
beating out there so what's going Isaac
well isn't that's just typical when
Moses left alone idris elba idea i
really like Idris Elba right now I want
to see him in everything and I heard his
voice and maybe I saw him under 10
pounds of makeup and prosthetics but i I
just I want him to be a great villain
yeah all right don't hide him from me if
that's what he is to be ninja turtles
too I don't like what you're doing to
these characters I don't like where this
franchise is going and that's all I have
to say I that's how I feel about this so
I'm annoyed by this trailer because it
makes me go huh and the thing was they
were trailers to the first one that made
me go huh and that's what made me watch
it and I'm a once and I'm really mad
that I watched it even there are things
of the trose that I can point to that I
that I like and that'd make me
interested to see it but the fact that
they tricked me into watching the last
one means that I can't take a series now
if I were to single those things out
really quickly I actually really like
the look and the and the vibe off of
bebop and Mark steady and I
say that as someone who actually does
not like it has never liked those
characters even as a kid because they
are the standard bumbling henchmen they
have never been anything other than that
so when you know people our age are
always like when will we give be Bobby
mark setting the movie my reaction has
always been why do you want that there's
stupid and pointless and useless the
fact that they made them look big and
intimidating and their reaction to being
joke that by the turtles is to go oh you
do jokes and then just charge them like
I like that that's cool um I there's
something about the way Raphael delivers
that line up we're just four brothers
who hate bullies and love this city I
kind of love that line I kind of love
that summation of who they are and
there's little moments like that across
this trailer I'm actually kind of
intrigued by the idea of Tyler Perry's
Baxter Stockman I so I'm seeing these
things and going maybe but as I said
there were things there in the trailers
for the first ones that maybe go maybe
and then the movie would ba I did
finally see the first one I water and
Netflix about two months ago and I think
live tweeted my experience because I
need to share that and the world was no
my page I don't actually remember a
whole lot of it now even just two months
ago but my overall impression was sort
of like I didn't really mind the things
that they changed and the updates they
made I mean it clearly this is going for
a new age group of new demographic so
they're making them a little bit
different and they're kind of adjusting
making sort of just just adapting and
read imagining certain things I didn't
have a problem with that my problem was
the movie was stupid yes it was a dog
the dialogue was bad the acting was
horrible and the little story made no
sense well it's probably going to be
stupid again but yeah I kind of see what
they're doing in the weights kind of
appealing to some of those endeavor as
they are introducing bebop and
Rocksteady who I agree I like the design
of them I thought the CGI on them look
really bad in this trailer at this point
I've just kind of swallowed that the CGI
sucks and yeah I mean even the look of
the turtles up in my mind I want to say
it looks better I don't know if it
actually does or
RFI's jet I've just gotten used to when
she's not complaining about that because
it's lost yeah uh yeah I thought they I
thought they looked bad then there's
these weird shifts like are they i'm
having like general cranes are me from
dimension I the the popular theories
that those are pieces of the Technodrome
and it's going to assemble itself if
that is the case they're cramming a lot
into this movie because shredders back
bebop and Rocksteady Baxter Stockman
Casey Jones Casey Jones kraang is like
the original cat yeah oh yes it didn't
bother me I just because my experience
was so much more recent I was just like
that oh this is gonna be dumb yeah yeah
and I think that says it well so that
brings us to independence day resurgence
I think I'm pretty up on like upcoming
movies and like what is coming out and
everything this will completely flew out
of my radar I had no idea at any point
they were making a sequel to this movie
so I saw a trail really like how I
remember seeing the first one I saw once
and i liked it i think but it just it
didn't affect me the way it affect a lot
like i know a lot of people love that
first in the penance day and I was just
coming it was fine i didn't have a
problem with but it didn't move me or
shake me in any noticeable way so I
wasn't excited or claiming for the
second one so when I did see that this
trailer came out I was like okay we're
out of curiosity like what is this going
to look like so it prob no problem in
macro okay how's it wise Jeff wise Judd
Hirsch invisible Oh Jed Jed Hirsch was
in the first one yeah so again all these
like there's the lesser Hemsworth
brother but there's a where's where's
Phil Smith with Will Smith is really
style come on is the glaring omission
and and the thing is I I don't love this
trailer and I don't the reason I don't
love this trailers because I really
enjoyed the first Independence Day and
part of the reason I really enjoyed the
first independence day even now is
because it does a really good balance of
having that disaster movie of the world
is coming to an end feel but also being
really really fun and a lot of that fun
came with will smith without the
injection of fun and lightheartedness
that
that character brought all you've got is
this the world is ending feel what
where's the punch to the face welcome to
earth and that's what I'm missing I also
hear was my biggest complaint of the
trailer is that the and they should have
been able to deliver on this was the
epic mix of the original independence
day trailer right when that first hit
like it felt big it felt like scary it
felt like you know in the front you know
that I was like wow I really want to see
this movie is Ivan see anything like
this like this is a real invasion of
Earth I didn't get that from this
trailer and I think it's partially
because this trailer is so busy and if
you go back and look at that original
independence day trailer it is insanely
efficient at what it does yeah right
which is it just shows the entrance
right I think it has the shot of the
White House getting blown up in that
first yeah that fur I have to go back
and rewatch it but this one is just like
well this one also physically ship that
looks like it's it dwarfs not like the
ship is like my size weight which I
actually think that I think that's part
of the inherent problem trying to do a
sequel did independence day in the first
place because you can you can make the
alien ships bigger and technically but I
don't think you can make them feel
bigger than those ships felt in that
first movie doesn't they were about the
size of cities okay you can make a ship
the size of Australia well you can do
that but no matter what you do it's
never going to feel any bigger then then
the way they shot and made those ships
feel in that first movie so there's that
and I guess that Len that leaves us with
fantastic beasts and where to find them
which I mean I wouldn't even really call
this a trailer was more like it was it
was like an announcement teaser and this
is a thing that will exist soon and
here's the thing it doesn't matter now
this movement is going to make a
gazillion dollars because it is the
thing we were totally we're never going
to have a mother Harry by another harry
potter movie i have one big fear okay
which is the screenplay was written by
JK Rowling being a novelist and
Englishmen rent or two very different
skills I have I have a feeling that they
probably
we did write the script yeah and then it
was rewritten by people who did not
fundamentally change it enough to be
given a writing credit under under guild
rules and actually probably by design
because I have a feeling they want to be
able to say written by JK rally as part
of the marketing and I actually think
trailers from here on out have to be
very very careful that they establish
why harry potter himself will not appear
in this i think what's the general
public the more casual fans of harry
potter realize that none of the
characters in the other movies are in
this i think it's i think it could
potentially have a very very big second
weekend drop-off once word gets out like
it depends on Harry there's not an elf
all day it will depend on the quality
but I think if they don't handle the
marketing carefully there is potential
fro again not from hardcore fans but
from the peep from the more general
audience who made the films as
financially successful as they were
right I I thought it was fine it didn't
leave much of an impression on me like I
read the Harry Potter books i dos' we
enjoyed them i saw the movies i mostly
enjoyed them when they were over i was
like ok I didn't need I didn't need to
ever come back this world I haven't read
whatever book this was based on or or if
it is based on a book or something I
know she did some of it gets based on a
short it was almost like a textbook the
children I think the biggest problem was
trailer was that it wasn't clever it's
also it's also not a traitor right yeah
that should say it should give you a
sense of the mood and the atmosphere in
the tone maybe we got a little bit of
that I also i only watched it once I
don't remember any dialogue really works
on this book so I can't really get there
were me I feel like I can't speak with
any kind of authority about this movie
put all right is that all than I think
well that's all the necessary concert we
can certainly find more what I what else
no no we go I have a feeling that
between now when I edit this and get it
out there will have been five more
trailers I think there's a trailer for
the jungle book coming out tomorrow oh
my god I so don't care anything you want
to plug
before we wrap it up I writer for a
comic book from residence and comics
called armadillo justice that is
currently available on Amazon and
comiXology and in a few scant comic book
stores so I got some podcasts it doesn't
matter hits go on itunes liver he's like
six of them great we'll go with that no
don't if I want to talk to you I'll find
you don't look right don't call us we'll
call you um and we won't call you tired
he never he never calls anybody thank
you guys for coming in to talk about all
this stuff good god it was a lot so
until next time this council is a jerk